this is the moment I've been waiting for
the special one-of-a-kind piece from
Nate Robinson's personal collection
thank you again no I can't wait to shred
these cabbie well let's see what we got
Kelly Oh some signature J's Nate our
ghost shoes game-worn game-worn bro
these are classic J's these are the
anniversary Jordans these didn't come
out I grew up watching The Smurfs as a
kid one of my favorite cartoons so I
always wanted to make just some cool
cartoon shoes so I made Smurfs 11 sweet
my shredder does not care no do not put
those up there
my god my stomach hurt I don't you want
to watch ha ha I'll be I'll be I'll be
down here ok so the question we have is
your year with the Chicago Bulls 2013
yet how many games did you play
all 82 that year and preseason and the
postseason
so however many games that was regular
season 82 you playing any two more 83
Kelly what do you think I think you got
a fatal I mean there's things called
load management here we have guys set
out like 13 to 15 games there's no way
he played all the games
well I'm what am i I'm one of a kind
look at me look at me I'm one of a kind
bros only one Nate Robinson Pro I'm not
gonna lie to you about playing all 82 I
was proud of this know you've heard from
Kelly load management you've heard from
Nate pleading his case this is the
moment of truth
are you gonna bet with Nate or are you
gonna fade Nate Kelly makes a good
points with a little management but I
think that started coming to play about
2013 with Gregg Popovich started
benching everybody so I would think Nate
would know how many games he played cuz
he only played one year with the team
I'm gonna say he played all 82 games
load management wasn't no thing back
then so he played all 82 games I'm going
with let's go to the morning to take
home one
no no give me the next Jersey it is part
of my contract that I get a scratch
something anything sir if you want the
tiger's eye
day
now that you live my man one of one whoa